cuando estudiamos la glucólisis y la
conversión del piruvato en acetil coa
luego entrábamos al ciclo de krebs que
también conocemos como el ciclo del
ácido cítrico y vimos que en algunos
pasos se producen directamente atp es
verdad tenemos la producción de atp pero
también dijimos que estábamos reduciendo
algunas moléculas de n además en línea
de h y luego dijimos que el nh puede
oxidarse también y la energía de dicha
oxidación puede utilizarse para generar
otros atp es verdad podríamos generar
más a tps en este caso y aunque nh es el
personaje principal digamos en este caso
también hay otras con enzimas
involucradas por ejemplo la coenzima q
que podemos ver aquí y bueno lo que
quiero platicar en este vídeo es el
proceso es todo sobre el proceso
mediante el cual obtenemos esa energía
del nh y esencialmente la conocemos como
fosforilación oxidativa muy bien
y el principal jugador cuando estamos
hablando de la respiración celular y la
fosforilación oxidativa en este caso
sería el nh que el nh en el proceso de
oxidarse en n además digamos éste puede
oxidarse en n además que podemos
observar que tiene una carga positiva
entonces podemos observar que es lo que
pasa en esta reacción desde el punto de
vista del nh que se está oxidando y
recordemos que la oxidación es pérdida
de electrones así que podemos obtener
también un protón aquí tenemos un protón
y también vamos a obtener dos electrones
verdad y esto es lo que ocurre cuando el
nh se oxida en nd así que vamos a poner
esto aquí obtenemos una reacción de
oxidación aquí tenemos una reacción de
oxidación y en este proceso se puede
liberar mucha energía y el receptor de
estos electrones verdad sería digamos
vamos a poner la reacción así vamos a
poner la reacción
tenemos 2 electrones también vamos a
tener dos protones aquí tenemos dos
protones y en realidad aquí uno podría
pensar que es media molécula de oxígeno
gaseoso pero en realidad todo esto lo
podemos pensar en moles verdad serían
dos moles de electrones dos moles de
protones y medio mol de oxígeno gaseoso
y esto nos da un molde de agua cierto
así que podemos pensar que el oxígeno es
el receptor final de dichos electrones
verdad bien y en realidad al oxígeno les
gusta
justamente oxidar de ahí viene la
palabra oxidación verdad aquí al oxígeno
lo que podemos decir es que le gusta
reducirse verdad es decir le gusta
acaparar electrones entonces decimos que
el oxígeno se redujo aquí ocurre que el
oxígeno
oxígeno se redujo de lujo
ahora bien si directamente
transfiriéramos estos electrones digamos
que se liberan del nh verdad si los
transfiriéramos directamente al oxígeno
entonces se liberaría tanta energía que
no seríamos capaces de asimilar la no
podría digamos servir para hacer
trabajos útiles así que el proceso de la
fosforilación oxidativa se trata de
hacer esto en una serie de pasos y lo
hacemos transfiriendo estos electrones
digamos pasando los de un receptor a
otro y cada vez que lo hacemos libera se
libera energía pero de forma más
controlada y puede generar trabajo en
este caso el trabajo es bombear protones
a través de la membrana y luego el
gradiente que se forma se puede puede
usarse para generar atp pero ya
llegaremos a ese punto más adelante así
que vamos a adentrarnos un poquito más
en este punto que acabo de mencionar y
aunque no vamos a entrar en todos los
detalles esto solo es para darnos un
panorama general de lo que es el proceso
entonces estos electrones
ir pasando de un receptor a otro por
ejemplo pueden pasar a la coenzima cubo
a la coenzima q después de pasar por la
coenzima q pueden ir al citocromo se
vamos a poner al citocromo sé muy bien y
puede continuar pasándose hacia otros
receptores hasta que finalmente puede
llegar a esta parte verdad a esta parte
donde los electrones pueden ser
aceptados por el oxígeno para poder
formar agua verdad y ahora recuerda que
en cada paso de esta digamos de esta
desde el paso de electrones verdad
tenemos liberación de energía aquí
tenemos liberación de energía acá
tenemos liberación también de energía
muy bien y esa energía se usa para
bombear protones de hidrógeno a través
de la membrana verdad y ese gradiente es
útil también para la formación de atp
así que vamos a adentrarnos ahora un
poco en esto último vamos a dibujar una
mitocondria
vamos a movernos hacia la derecha y aquí
vamos a pintar nuestra mitocondria
verdad aquí tenemos la membrana externa
y ahora vamos a pintar una pedazo
digamos vamos a pintar un poco la
membrana interna digamos más o menos
algo así verdad ahí tenemos los pliegues
de la membrana interna verdad que
conocemos como crestas y sólo para hacer
un poquito más claros vamos a poner que
es cada cosa aquí tenemos la membrana
externa la membrana externa acá esta
sería la membrana interna ésta es la
membrana interna y al espacio digamos
comprendido entre estas dos membranas
este este espacio que tenemos aquí se le
conocen justamente como el espacio inter
- o verdad aquí está el espacio espacio
interno
ínter membranoso membranoso muy bien y
puedes notar que tenemos otro espacio
verdad tenemos el espacio que está
dentro de la membrana interna este
espacio que tenemos aquí ya éste se le
conoce como matriz muy bien esta es la
matriz de la mitocondria muy bien y de
hecho es aquí en donde se lleva a cabo
el ciclo de krebs verdad que es en donde
se produce la mayor parte de los nh es
así que voy a poner este pequeño ciclo
para representar que aquí se lleva a
cabo el ciclo de krebs y no sólo se
produce la mayor parte de los nh sino
que también hay o se producen otras con
enzimas que ya hemos mencionado verdad
por ejemplo mencionamos el fadh 2 verdad
efe efe de h 2 luego se utiliza para
reducir a la coenzima q verdad y
producir q h 2 y luego está participa en
la fosforilación oxidativa y de ahí que
en realidad puedas
fijarte en cualquiera de estos en
particular yo me voy a centrar en coche
2 bueno aunque mejor vamos a centrarnos
sólo en nh porque en realidad atraviesan
procesos digamos similares de hecho fadh
h 2 en realidad entran más adelante en
la cadena de transporte de electrones y
de hecho no producen tanta energía pero
aún así son útiles para producir atp
ahora bien ya dijimos el ciclo de krebs
ocurre en la matriz de nuestra
mitocondria pero ahora vamos a hacer un
acercamiento a la membrana interna vamos
a hacer un acercamiento a este pedazo
vamos a hacer un acercamiento verdad y
qué es lo que vamos a observar bueno en
realidad es una membrana verdad y como
toda membrana está formada por una
bicapa de fosfolípidos muy bien vamos a
poner esa bicapa de fosfolípidos y la
voy a hacer suficientemente amplia para
que quede muy claro qué es lo que está
ocurriendo aquí
a poner otra serie d
aquí de las cabezas verdad de nuestra
capa aquí tenemos las cabezas y tenemos
las colas cierto entonces no voy a
pintar las cosas de todos sino así
simplemente aunque sea un poco espaciado
y ahora vamos del otro lado entonces
esta es la bicapa de fosfolípidos porque
es como cualquier membrana verdad y
también vamos a tener unas proteínas que
atraviesan esta esta bicapa verdad aquí
podríamos tener una primera proteína
verdad tenemos una proteína que
atraviesa esta bicapa en realidad estas
son enzimas que de hecho son complejos
proteínicos que facilitan la
fosforilación oxidativa vamos a poner
otro par de estas proteínas no sé cuál
se exactamente la geometría de estas
pero sólo para que quede claro vamos a
ponerlo así vamos a poner una tercera
y una tercera por acá verdad vamos a
poner una tercera y vamos a extender un
poquito más nuestra bicapa verdad vamos
a poner un poco más de estas que vamos a
extenderlo aquí también muy bien lo que
ocurre es que cuando tenemos nh tenemos
aquí
nh y cede digamos los el don a los
protones y electrones entonces se
convierte en línea de más verdad esto es
lo que vimos en esta reacción de
oxidación y estos electrones digamos van
a ir con otro receptor por acá y luego
con otro y luego con otro y así
sucesivamente van a seguir nuestra
cadena de transporte de electrones y a
medida que la energía se libera se
emplea para bomber es para bombear
protones de la matriz digamos la matriz
es lo que se encuentra del lado
izquierdo aquí tenemos
matriz vamos a escribirlo bien aquí
tenemos la matriz de la mitocondria muy
bien y los protones son bombeados hacia
digamos hacia el espacio intervendrán
oso que se encuentra del lado derecho
verdad aquí estaría la matriz y del otro
lado tenemos el espacio inter - entonces
a medida que los electrones van yendo de
estados de energía más altos a estados
de energía más bajos hasta digamos
llegar al agua como vimos en esta
reacción entonces se va generando un
gradiente de protones verdad es decir
estamos aumentando la concentración de
protones del lado derecho es decir en el
espacio internet gran uso y entonces
todo esto en realidad es energía
almacenada verdad ya que esto es en
esencia un gradiente electroquímico y
con toda esta carga querrán alejarse
mutuamente y quizás quieran ir a este
lado digamos al lado de la matriz en
donde hay una menor concentración de
protones es decir a donde hay menos
carga positiva
vamos a tener una concentración más alta
en hidrógeno del lado derecho por eso
digamos por difusión tenderán a ir a
zonas con menor concentración por
ejemplo nuevamente hacia la matriz
verdad ya que aquí habrá una menor
concentración de hidrógenos y este es el
momento adecuado para usar esta energía
para producir atp y la forma de hacerlo
es utilizando un complejo proteínico que
se le conoce como atp sin tasa entonces
voy a tratar de esbozar un dibujo de la
atp sin tasa digamos tiene como una
estructura aquí tiene por aquí como una
especie de eje y tiene otra estructura
más o menos de ese estilo en realidad la
estructura de la atp sintasa es
fascinante y está atp sintasa atraviesa
la membrana y de hecho tiene una
estructura mecánica muy bien hecha más o
menos se ve así aunque después te voy a
enseñar un mejor diagrama y lo que pasa
es que ésta está atp sin casa permite
que estos protones de hidrógeno sigan
digamos fluyendo
en dirección contraria a su gradiente
electroquímico verdad y de hecho hacen
que este eje gire vamos a pintarlo así
hacen que esté gire a medida que los
protones van viajando hacia la matriz y
bueno hay que recordar que todo este eje
no es liso toda la atp sin tasa en
realidad no es que esté hecho como de
metal verdad como como ocurre en las
máquinas en realidad todo esto está
hecho de aminoácidos verdad entonces no
es liso en realidad se ve bastante más
complicado ya veremos una imagen más
adelante verdad y no hay que olvidar que
esto en realidad está hecho de
aminoácidos y lo que ocurre es que
tenemos digamos a dps alojados por aquí
déjenme pintarlos por ejemplo aquí
podemos tener a dps alojados por acá y
podríamos tener un grupo fosfato verdad
en realidad hay tres sitios en donde
puede ocurrir esto verdad donde tenemos
el pp con un grupo fosfato verdad y
digamos hay otro tercer sitio que no voy
a pintar por acá pero bueno lo que va a
ocurrir en esencia es que sigue
cambiando la conformación de la proteína
y lo que ocurre es que embona el grupo
fosfato con el atp tomando digamos
energía para sellarlo y formar al final
el atp entonces cuando el atp está
digamos ya formado éste ya no se une al
sitio activo y le permite liberarse
entonces aquí tenemos la liberación del
atp verdad entonces casi podríamos
pensar esto como si fuera una turbina
cierto en realidad el agua digamos
entrar como si entrara por aquí y luego
esa energía se utiliza para generar
electricidad
aquí lo que entra son los protones de
hidrógeno y este movimiento rotatorio se
usa para unir el fosfato con el atp
verdad entonces de esta forma obtenemos
el atp y esta es en realidad algo que
está ocurriendo en nuestros cuerpos en
este preciso momento incluso para que
pueda yo hablar en este momento necesito
energía y que se generen los atp es
ahora para tener una mejor apreciación
de qué es lo que ocurre voy a mostrarles
una imagen más precisa de lo que es la
atp sin casa
aquí lo tenemos y con base en este
diagrama aquí digamos vamos a pintar el
espacio intervendrán oso sería esta
parte de arriba esto sería el espacio
inter membranoso y si ese es el espacio
intervendrán oso entonces aquí tendremos
la matriz verdad esto que tenemos como
en gris es nuestra bicapa de
fosfolípidos es decir es nuestra
membrana vamos a poner aquí algunas
algunas cabezas y colas aquí tenemos
una capa aquí tenemos la otra verdad
esta es la membrana y la membrana
interna de la mitocondria que en
realidad podría hacer un pliegue de la
membrana es decir podría ser una cresta
verdad entonces los protones de
hidrógeno se acumulan en el espacio
intervendrán huso aquí vamos a tener
acumulación de protones verdad de este
lado y estos se acumulan debido a la
cadena de transporte de electrones luego
fluyen en dirección opuesta al gradiente
electroquímico verdad van fluyendo
digamos en esta dirección
hacen girar este rotor y permiten la
creación de atp es por aquí entonces
digamos vamos a tener por aquí a dp voy
a ponerlo aquí vamos a tener a dp que se
va a unir con un grupo fosfato se va a
unir con un grupo fosfato y esto nos va
a producir atp ese es el final digamos
vamos a tener atp y esto es fascinante
en realidad esto está ocurriendo en las
células de tu cuerpo en este mismo
momento
en cierto sentido es lo que permite que
tú que tu realidad sea posible verdad
así que espero que tengas una mejor
apreciación de todo esto ya hemos estado
hablando bastante tiempo sobre la
respiración celular verdad ya hemos
hablado de la glucólisis por ejemplo
hemos hablado de cómo se produce el atp
directamente de la glucólisis o también
cómo se produce atp en el ciclo de krebs
verdad aquí tenemos la formación de atp
en el ciclo de krebs pero en realidad la
mayor parte de la energía proviene de la
reducción de estas coenzimas por ejemplo
n además en nh o por ejemplo también
estas de por acá verdad porque luego en
la fosforilación oxidativa se va a
oxidar estas con enzimas verdad y en la
cadena de transporte de electrones
podemos usar la oxidación del nh para
bombear protones hacia el espacio
intervendrán oso y luego se les permite
entrar de vuelta a la matriz verdad
haciendo funcionar
atp sin tasa que es 12 más o menos aquí
verdad la atp sin tasa y que esto al
final pueda producir atp que es la
moneda energética de los sistemas
biológicos